[Music]
okay Stuber sauce toover Stuber is kind
of a cop buddy flick very much in the
kind of the eighties genre but it's set
of course in modern times I [ __ ]
liked it bad I just I thought the tone
was right
I thought the script was right the humor
was spot-on
the action the violence just yeah as a
perfect summer action movie comedy movie
it really was a lot of fun I really got
I really did get that like throwback
it's you know it's like it doesn't seem
like an 80s movie and like how it looks
but the the tone of it and like the way
it's edited and stuff like that is very
much like an old 80s action movie yeah
that has a lot of comedy in it but it's
also very violent it was yeah a lot more
violent than I was expecting it was like
a lot of us worried I guess but it was
kind of a little bit gory it also has
like an odd couple angle yeah yeah you
got a real [ __ ] macho kind of
throwback cop and he has LASIK surgery
done and just at the drop of a hat one
of his one of the guys he works with
says hey man we got to finish this case
and you know because he was trying to
find the guys who killed his partner
yeah so he said [ __ ] it so he's decided
he's gonna do this case even though he
can't see Rex his car but he grabs this
dude who's [ __ ] got it uber and
forces this guy on the mission with him
and he's a total [ __ ] but it's funny
out as it goes how it goes and he kind
of teaches the guy to man up and then in
a way [ __ ] what does the inventions
yeah Vincent Vincent learns to kind of
like Vic or something I think his name
is Vic Vic kinda learns to appreciate
certain things that could do it's good
movie I liked it a lot yeah I had been
seeing you know because they really did
like a big push for this and you know
they said there was a lot of trailers
for it and stuff and it's like I thought
it was gonna be funny but I was like oh
it's you know that'll probably be kind
of entertaining stuff but it was
actually much better than I was
expecting yeah like I said it was
you know it's obviously very r-rated it
was very very violent that was like just
a lot of swearing like the jokes were
all just really really funny
I thought I don't even think that there
was like any jokes that didn't land or
they're not funny that's like it was
awkward and it was also really really
fast-paced it never really it's only an
hour and a half long crowd loved it yeah
and it just like went along at a good
clip it was just like a fun it's just
like a Superman action [ __ ] movie
yeah it was like it way better than I
was expecting
yeah good car chases good flipping cars
you know [ __ ] blowing up cool guns
fights a lot of you know [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] habit and deer deer in the fights
it's just the all around all around good
movie they just kind of nailed it for
that genre you know I liked it yeah some
people might you know and they they took
a lot of the stereotypes from the 80s
action flicks yeah and kind of turn them
on the head like a conflict they always
end up you know fun looking for clues in
a strip club
yeah always in a strip club yeah all
right so they did that there's a lot of
clues in stir yeah yeah those a clue to
strip club and when they get there it's
all men it's funny
yeah but yeah I recommend it yeah like I
said I liked it much more than I was
expecting to cuz like the trailer looks
pretty funny but it was actually much
much funnier much better yeah that I was
expecting a lot more violent like I said
you
okay crawl crawl was kind of a
father-daughter adventure survival flick
happening here in Florida in Gainesville
in Gainesville in the middle of a badass
hurricane she tries to get into this
town it's closed off because the
emergency in emergencies gone down the
roads are closed she can't get over dad
[ __ ] it she's gonna find him she gets
there he's underneath the house he'd
been tagged by an alligator
he was second stuck in the crawlspace so
he's got to get her out and her she's
got to get him out and there's always
alligators stopping them yeah and
there's all the water level it's just a
lot of railroads and the dogs with them
and everything I got I'm kind of mixed
on this one it felt like a Christian
movie to me it just did the way it
looked the way it the [ __ ] bad
dialogue it just did it felt like it was
a religious movie to be like it did yeah
it's just I had that you know you know
you know those like religious movies
about dogs like dog movie nothing like
it said to me if there's something about
it you know something my spider senses
are telling me something about it it
just okay it started off kind of slow
alright but then once it picked up I
kind of got interested in it alright
but then as things went on there's more
more alligator action and everything I
could no longer suspend my disbelief on
that yeah I mean the alligators a little
too much like sharks to me are they yeah
and also you didn't even have the
alligators also you had the Hurricanes
yeah the hurricane so it was like you
know not these two peoples day I mean
pretty much everything they tried to do
like
horribly wrong yeah and so you know the
tension kept ratcheting up like I said
it's just to me it seemed like it's not
as it wasn't as like ridiculous as like
sharknado or anything like that I wish
it was though but it you know you do
kind of have to like suspend your
disbelief like I said it was realistic
up to a point but you know then after
that you just kind of had to roll with
it and be like yeah it's a bunch of
alligators and a hurricane and they're
just trying to get out it's a very
simple story it's pretty much just that
in one house they're in the crawl space
we're pretty much to hop in the movie or
more than half of it and then you know
so it's like all the [ __ ] they're trying
to do to escape I actually kind of like
it was a lot of fun it had some good
gore effects in it
the alligators will CGI clearly yeah
except for probably I think some of the
underwater shots where real alligators
and I find alligators very scary so to
me this kind of like wig me out
alligator movies in shark movie has
always been a flake wig me out cuz that
[ __ ] could eat you for real and so I was
like what to me to me the tone was a
very serious it was great it wasn't like
wacky like over-the-top but then weird
[ __ ] [ __ ] started happening I'm like
gone no no the dude's got a broken leg
they showed it it was a compound
fracture yeah but he put a splint on it
well he pulled the bone back in yeah but
and then he's walking around on it I've
had broken our support no you ain't
going nowhere I watched him he was
walking you can't [ __ ] watch it and
then later on he gets his arm bit off
and then he's having the conversations
after his arm got torn off no you lose a
limb you're [ __ ] up you're not even
thinking rationally you lose a lot of
blood like people get yeah nothing
happened but yeah it's a movie and like
I said it's it's just like a fun summer
monster I don't care how late and I
don't care how good that girl was in
terms of as a swimmer you can't outswim
[ __ ] okay well no
I wouldn't have even tried to be like
well she was a swimmin alligators
playing the baby honest I would rather
just drown they get eaten by us so when
you have this serious tone but then you
have this stuff that's obviously
impossible to me I don't like that if
you're gonna have [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] do
it like sharknado yeah
you know see ya have fun with it yeah I
mean and then I like it
yeah to that I'm like okay I get because
you know I know they're not trying to
insult my intelligence
yeah they're just trying to pull it just
try it yeah they're late right no that
had a fun movie to show you some [ __ ] I
like yeah okay yeah you know like this
you know Stewart did that yeah yeah it's
Stewart did that so you know they
impossible [ __ ] happened and they just
said yes it was impossible like Joss
there was good there was good humor in
that one man I really like that like I
said I didn't like none of the jokes
like were duds or anything that it just
was like all of the dialogue and the two
of them were like really funny together
the chemistry between them was very
funny crawl wasn't bad it wasn't bad the
crowds seemed to like it's a simple
Monty like I said you need to suspend
your disbelief like a bunch of
alligators like going after people and
you know obviously they're doing things
that probably a normal person would not
be able to do yeah life like I said they
do that in a lot of between these
between these two movies tonight the
best uber kick his ass Stewart kicked
ass and I thought that was much better
than crawl yeah I mean and I thought it
was gonna be the other way around yeah
like I said they're two very different
kinds of movies but yeah I think Stuber
was more entertaining
yes a lot weren't it saying I did like
the alligator one but I can see what
you're saying they maybe should have
made it like more ridiculous yeah I
liked it
until the final till the final like the
third act and right when it started to
get really [ __ ] out there yeah I mean
the town still remains serious and like
now yeah like now I started to kind of
reject eyes that that doesn't happen
yeah come on man you can't believe but
if they you know if it it if it had been
over the top from the very beginning and
fun from the beginning yeah I would have
enjoyed it yeah
yeah but I've enjoyed a lot better
[Music]